estamos en el problema número 19 el
problema número 19 que me dice si x si x
elevado a la menos cuatro tercios al
menos cuatro tercios es lo mismo que acá
elevado a la menos 2 esto por una parte
por otra parte y elevado a la cuatro
tercios positivo a la cuatro tercios
esto es lo mismo que en el elevado al
cuadrado entonces lo que me preguntan es
cuánto vale x por james esto elevado a
la menos dos tercios ok
bueno pues bueno la buena noticia es que
es el último problema el penúltimo
problema de esta sección número 7 del
examen número 5 la mala es que tenemos
que recordar las leyes los exponentes
bueno realmente no es mala noticia pero
vamos a recordarlos en primer lugar lo
que se me ocurre aquí es que esto lo
puede escribir como x elevado a la menos
dos tercios
james elevado a la menos dos tercios
esto porque recuerda que cada una de las
variables que están adentro de este
paréntesis van a obtener este exponente
o dicho de otra manera sus exponentes
van a pasar multiplicándose pero como
podemos encontrar x a la menos dos
tercios y por otra parte como podemos
encontrar que a la menos dos tercios
usando esta información que tengo aquí
es decir lo que quiero es expresar x a
la menos dos tercios en términos de
camps y menos dos tercios en términos de
n cuadrada bueno pues lo que se me
ocurre es partir de que tengo x elevado
a la menos cuatro tercios esto es igual
a k elevado en la menos 2 pero yo lo que
quiero es llegar a x elevado a la menos
dos tercios por lo tanto para obtener x
elevado a la menos dos tercios
tengo que elevar esta x a una cierta
potencia y si yo lo que quiero llegar de
aquí acá esencialmente lo que busco es
una ecuación que diga menos cuatro
tercios multiplicado por una cierta
variable le voy a poner
esto tiene que ser igual a menos dos
tercios porque estoy buscando esto
porque recuerda que si yo pongo una
potencia aquí llamada a estas potencias
se van a pasar multiplicándose y cuánto
es esto bueno pues no es lo mismo que
menos dos tercios y a éste lo voy a
pasar como su inverso multiplicativo a
es igual a menos dos tercios por menos
tres cuartos y bueno de aquí este menos
con este menos se va este tres con este
13 van y me queda 2 entre 4 lo cual es
un medio a debe de valer un medio ok
entonces en lugar de a voy a escribir un
medio y también lo que haga de un lado
lo voy a hacer del otro lado aquí un
medio es decir que x elevado a la y
cuánto es menos cuatro tercios por un
medio bueno pues puedo cancelar este 2
con este 4 y me van a quedar menos dos
tercios x elevado a menos dos tercios es
lo mismo que acá elevado a la menos dos
por un medio es lo mismo que menos uno
y esto es muy importante así que lo voy
a atrapar por aquí esto es muy
importante porque es el valor que voy a
sustituir aquí en términos de acá pero
bueno esto por una parte porque por otra
parte tengo y elevado a la menos dos
tercios a lo que quiero llegar este
elevado la menos dos tercios pero yo sé
y voy a utilizar el mismo color que ya
elevado de cuatro tercios que he elevado
a la cuatro tercios es igual a n
cuadrada ok y como quiero llegar a esto
de camps pues esencialmente lo que tengo
que hacer es muy parecido voy a elevar
esta y elevado a la cuatro tercios a una
potencia bien para que me dé menos dos
tercios es decir que voy a obtener que
cuatro tercios cuatro tercios por b esto
tiene que ser igual a menos dos tercios
y si de aquí despejo avn voy a obtener
que es lo mismo que menos dos tercios
que multiplica a tres cuartos
multiplicando por el inverso
multiplicativo de cuatro tercios y aquí
éste cuando éste se van y me queda menos
uno
- un medio es decir que me vale menos un
medio y lo que haga de un lado lo voy a
hacer también del otro lado aquí menos
un medio de tal manera que me va a
quedar que jeff o no ya no me cabe por
acá déjame tratar de mover pesaron un
poco para terminar de escribirlo
james elevado a la técnica en vez de
herramienta y elevado a la menos dos
tercios esto es igual a n cuadrada
elevada a la menos un medio me queda n
elevada a la menos uno perfecto este
también de aquí lo voy a ocupar este es
el valor que voy a poner justo aquí ok
es decir que que me va a quedar de
resultado me va a quedar que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que x elevado a la
menos dos tercios pero esto es k elevado
la menos 1 k elevado a la menos 1 esto
que a su vez multiplican ha elevado a la
menos dos tercios pero he elevado a la
menos dos tercios es en elevado a la
menos uno en elevado a la menos uno o
dicho de otra manera esto es exactamente
lo mismo que acá por n elevado a la
menos 1 y recuerda que cuando tengo una
potencia negativa estos dos pueden pasar
dividiendo estos pueden pasar dividiendo
a la potencia 1
uno entre acá por el que por cierto es
el inciso a de lujo bueno esta es una
forma de resolver el problema número 19
pero también se me ocurre que puedo
hacer otra forma y tal vez no tan
enredada no lo sé vamos a intentar
hacerlo desde otra perspectiva de este
mismo problema así que déjenme borrar
todo esto que tengo aquí voy a borrar
todo esto que tengo aquí todo todo todo
todo todo esto me voy a quedar con esto
que tengo aquí y qué te parece si
primero antes de ver qué es lo que me
voy a preguntar voy a despejar de que x
x me voy a quedar con esto de aquí x
elevado a la menos cuatro tercios y esto
es igual a k elevado a la menos 2 y
ahora voy a llevar a ambas partes de
esta igualdad por el inverso
multiplicativo de cuatro tercios que es
menos tres cuartos menos tres cuartos y
aquí también a esto lo voy a elevar a la
menos tres cuartos de tal manera que
o no este 4 está muy feo de tal manera
que estos dos se van a ir porque son
inversos multiplicativos y me va a
quedar que x es igual a camps elevado a
la menos por menos es más 2 entre 4 es
un medio no va a quedar acá elevado a la
tres medios perfecto ahora voy a hacer
lo mismo con james que tengo que he
elevado a la cuatro tercios esto es
igual a n cuadrada y si ahora elevó esta
parte por el inverso multiplicativo de
cuatro tercios es decir tres cuartos y
también esta parte lo voy a llevar por
el inverso multiplicativos de cuatro
tercios es decir tres cuartos me va a
quedar que estos dos se van a ir y
obtengo que james es lo mismo que n
elevado a la dos por tres cuartos es lo
mismo que tres medios tres medios ok ya
tengo el valor de james ya tenemos valor
de x estos valores son muy importantes
tengo este de aquí
y tengo este de aquí y ahora sí si lo
que me preguntan es cuánto vale x por
james elevado a su vez a la menos dos
tercios
pues ahora puedo sustituir cuánto vale x
y cuánto vale y entonces esto es lo
mismo que acá elevado a la tres medios
que multiplica a en elevado a la tres
medios y todo esto elevado a la menos
dos tercios y cuántos esto bueno pues si
te das cuenta estos dos números casi son
el inverso multiplicativo la única
diferencia es que éste tiene signo
negativo por lo tanto esto es lo mismo
que acá elevado a la menos uno por n
elevado a la menos 1 pasa lo mismo con
la n iv entonces esto es lo mismo que
uno entre k por él ya está dos formas de
ver el mismo problema y llegar a la
misma solución bueno está de lujo este
fue el problema número 19 pero nos hace
falta 1 así que vamos al último problema
de esta sección problema número 20
y me dan dos gráficas así que déjame
hacerlas una vez
tengo esta gráfica de que esto es el mr
mh
por acá tengo a mi eje de las x más o
menos así por acá tengo a mi eje de
leyes gay y por acá tengo a mi eje de
las x de lujo y además me dan algunos
datos este es el eje valles este es el
eje de asx ok por acá pasa lo mismo el
eje y el eje de las equis y me dan
algunos puntos
me dicen primero que esta gráfica pasa
por el punto menos 20 aquí tengo al
menos 1 aquí tengo al menos 2 y estoy en
este punto de aquí que es el menos 20
menos 20 ok
después pasó por el punto menos 13 menos
1 y tengo que subir 312
por aquí va a pasar mi gráfica por el
punto menos 13 ok
después bajó hasta el origen ok y
después vuelvo a bajar hasta el punto
menos 1 como al menos 3 aquí tengo menos
1 - 2 - 3 aquí tengo 1 y estoy en el
punto 1 coma menos tres uno coma menos
tres y después dice que vuelvo a subir
al punto 20 a este punto de aquí justo
por aquí voy a pasar en el punto 2,0 y
después sigo subiendo es decir que la
gráfica de esta función se va a ver más
o menos así tengo una función que sube
por aquí llega a este punto sube está
este punto después empieza a bajar ok y
después vuelve a bajar tomo este punto y
después sube por aquí hasta el infinito
ok y aquí tengo otra función que se
llama gdx que por cierto me dicen que su
punto máximo está en el 21
2,1 aquí está mi punto máximo y después
tengo el punto mínimo en el 4,5
2 x 1 2 3 4 5 por aquí está un punto
mínimo se ve una gráfica que sube por
aquí llega hasta este punto toca baja
llega hasta este punto tocaba acá y
después vuelve a subir desde el infinito
perfecto
y bueno qué datos me dan me dicen que
esta es la función f x f de x que por
cierto dice que la función f está
definida de la siguiente manera
fx es exactamente lo mismo que x cúbica
menos 4x perfecto ok y ésta me dice que
es la función de x
esta es la función gtx que por cierto me
dicen que está definida de la siguiente
manera 7 x es la misma función que fx
solamente que vista como f de x + h ya
esto le sumamos que perfecto y lo que
nos preguntan es cuánto vale h por camps
lo que quiero saber es cuánto vale 8
porque ahí lo voy a poner aquí h por acá
esto lo que quiero saber ahora lo que
quiero que recordemos es que es lo que
pasa con la gráfica de una función
cuando yo le sumó una constante cam y
cuando yo le sumo aquí adentro de este
paréntesis una constante h
primero pensemos con camps si yo le sumó
una constante camps lo que está pasando
a esta gráfica sería que está subiendo o
está bajando ahora de lo que depende de
que suba o baje es del signo de camps si
acá es positiva cada vez mayor que cero
entonces la gráfica se desplaza hacia
arriba si acá es negativa sí que es
menor que cero entonces la gráfica se
desplaza hacia abajo ahora pensemos un
poco en h si yo tengo una constante h
que adentro de este paréntesis lo que
voy a hacer es mover esta gráfica oa la
derecha oa la izquierda depende del
signo de h
si es positiva entonces se mueve se la
izquierda si es mayor que cero entonces
se mueve hacia la izquierda
ojo contrario a lo que se cree contrario
lo que pensarías se va a mover hacia la
izquierda y de manera contraria si h es
negativa entonces se va a mover hacia la
derecha ahora quiero que te des cuenta
que estas dos gráficas son iguales la
única diferencia es que esta gráfica amd
déjame ver si puedo hacer lo que pasó
este punto se movió hasta
un cierto valor aunque hasta acá un
cierto valor y después bajo otro cierto
valor de hecho bajó hasta acá otro
cierto valor y de igual manera para este
punto este punto si te das cuenta se
movió en la misma cantidad para acá ok y
después bajo esa misma cantidad por lo
tanto toda la gráfica se desplazó
primero a la derecha y después hacia
abajo esta gráfica no giro en ningún
momento ni se hizo grande ni se hizo
pequeña ni se cortó en pedacitos sigue
intacta lo único que pasó es que la
gráfica se movió a la derecha y después
está hacia abajo ahora sí h lo que me
dice es cuando se mueve a la derecha o
hacia la izquierda vamos a ver cuánto se
movió se movió 123 se movió 3 hacia la
derecha por lo tanto si nos movemos a la
derecha h debe ser negativa es decir que
h vale 3 porque nos movimos 3 hacia la
derecha pero negativos h vale menos 3 ok
y qué pasó con cam bueno ya que llegamos
a movernos a este punto bajamos una dos
unidades por lo tanto como este punto
ahora se sitúa justo aquí justo aquí
entonces me moví para abajo dos unidades
cada vez es negativo
simón para abajo dos unidades es decir
que acá vale menos dos cuando tengo una
hd menos tres y una cada menos dos la
gráfica se mueve hasta este punto y
también este punto llegaría hasta acá
perfecto ahora lo que me pregunta es
cuánto vale h por camps y ya acabamos
este problema h por acá es lo mismo que
menos 3 x menos 2 lo cual es lo mismo
que 6 y ya está la solución de este
problema que por cierto es el inciso y
me quedé sin tiempo hasta la próxima